Hi everyone.
Welcome to my talk, moving
from Node.js to Dart.
In the end, if
you guys are lucky
I'll actually fly on a bird.
We'll see about that.
So this talk is about
my personal experience
in taking a production Node.js
API and moving it to Dart.
This API isn't large scale.
It's not serving
millions of users.
It's just a personal app that
we had a stock simulator game
and why we moved to Dart,
and you know our experiences.
In my opinion, Dart is
a really powerful VM
and is a really amazing syntax.
I mean, that's why I'm here.
So using that for API
development is pretty cool.
What are we gonna talk about?
We'll talk about Node.js
to Dart, the pros and cons
and the differences
in moving from Node.js
to Dart and the frameworks
and differences there.
We'll talk about
thinking in Dart.
This is interesting because
it's really different paradigms.
So we'll talk about how to
really think in Dart when
you're coming from Node.js and
utilizing Dart's most powerful
features for API development.
Next, we'll talk about
debugging in Dart.
I'm not a perfect developer.
I have bugs so Dart really
helps out with that.
And lastly, most important
part, getting it out there.
So how to deploy a Dart
application to an Amazon cloud.
Before that, a little bit about
me because I don't think anyone
knows me.
Pardon, oh.
I'm an entrepreneur
and an engineer.
I've been writing APIs
is for the past 10 years
in ColdFusion first,
Node.js, and now Dart.
Anyone done any
ColdFusion development?
Yeah, those are my homies.
ColdFusion was amazing back
in the day and now it's--
And I've deployed many
large-scale Node.js APIs.
I've written recommendation
engines, real-time chat
servers, and stuff
so it's kind of cool.
I've done a bunch
of stuff there.
I'm also an Android and
sometimes an iOS developer.
I come from a Flex
background like many of you
here, which is really weird.
And fun fact, I actually
wrote Flex 2 in Action way
back in the day, so I don't
know if anyone read that.
And I've written a handful
of Dart web projects
for our clients.
These are not API projects
just like Dart Polymer.
And that's when I really
started getting exposed to Dart
and enjoying it how well it
is because I was doing lots
of JavaScript stuff, Angular,
JS, and just jQuery stuff
and it was driving me crazy.
Lastly, but not least, I
work at an amazing company
called LEAGUE during the day.
That's where I do lots
of Android development,
completely separate from
Dart but, threw that in.
So let's take a look
at The Backstory.
The animated-- perfect.
So this is a game.
It's called the Market Wolf
and it's a native Android stock
simulator game.
If anyone wants to learn
how the stock market works
you can download
this and play it.
It's by no means full featured
but it's just a fun game
and you can compare
with each other.
And if you and your friends
are on there you can see,
hey, I made a million dollars.
You suck.
All that stuff, right?
Originally, it was
written in Node.js.
It uses RethinkDB
as its data store
in the back-end, uses
lots of WebSockets
because we're scraping stuff
from Yahoo's stock ticker stuff
and pushing it to your clients
so all that stuff has to happen
in real-time, pseudo real-time.
It's every like two
seconds because we're not
going to pay NASDAQ for all
those stock ticker quotes.
And it's medium size API.
It's not tremendously large
but it's not like three lines.
It facilitates a lot of stuff
like when you're buying stock,
selling stock, searching
stocks, figuring out
setting up stop limits
and all that crazy stuff.
And now it's powered by a Dart
API, which is why I'm here.
So let's take a look
at the live demo.
And what's crazy
about this demo is
I actually logged out
of the application
so this is going to
be a bit interesting.
All righty.
So everyone can see that.
I'm going to start Market Wolf.
I hope everything works.
So here it is, the login screen.
So now all this is being
powered by Dart in the back-end.
So when I hit sign-in
with Facebook, what we do
is we get the user's
Facebook credentials
and send over that
auth token to Dart.
And then on Dart we
authenticate the user,
see if he's registered and
all that fun stuff there.
So I'm going to hit
it, fingers crossed.
Hopefully it works.
Boom.
All right, so now we
show a litle [? FTE ?].
Unfortunately, the stock
market is actually closed
when I'm giving
this talk so what
I did was I just rigged up our
server to send out random stock
quotes, so which is why Amazon
is fluctuating like crazy right
now.
And so all that will work.
And now I can hit start
searching for stocks.
So if I'm searching
for Google, you
can see it's happening
in real-time.
That's our WebSocket stuff.
Google coming in.
I can hit it.
It loads up the
Google stock thing.
I can read a bunch of
news if I'm interested.
And then I can buy
stock and all this
is happening using
a Dart back-end.
Hit Buy Stock.
It goes and creates an account.
And yeah, there we go.
And also the most
important part of this
is I'm able to compare my net
gain with all the other users
on the system right now.
So you can see [INAUDIBLE]
has lost a lot of money.
He's in debt,
whereas I made $5,000
and I think that's just because
I rigged up this entire thing.
It's insider trading.
So that's basically
the application.
So it works.
It was great.
We actually built the Android
app about like six months ago,
seven months ago in our free
time and we launched it.
It has a different name.
It was called Stock Market
Simulator back then.
And then I started doing
a lot Dart development.
I said, you know what, the
Node.js API is good but there
are some difficulties in it.
So why would I want to
switch from Node.js to Dart?
Number one was the tooling and
debugging support for Node.js
is a pain.
Now there's WebStorm and
stuff but it's not as great
as once I started
using Dart development.
Dart felt good.
Nose.js didn't feel right.
I was already using Dart
and Polymer and stuff
so I knew the Dart syntax.
I liked it and I
wanted to learn more
on how I can deploy
this on the server.
Has anyone done any Dart
server development here?
A few people, OK, great.
So and Node didn't seem
to be the right answer.
And the reason why is our API,
there's a WebSocket component.
There is a real-time
stock fetching component.
And there's a real-time
leaderboard updating.
So if I kept the
application running,
every five seconds a
leaderboard updates
with my current
portfolio and everyone
can see how much I made
and the next instance I
lost all my life savings.
So that's all that's happening.
With a single Node.js
instance, which
is single threaded and
running in an event loop,
stuff starts
blocking because you
are getting a lot
of stock quotes,
parsing them out, and
putting into our data
structures and all that stuff.
So the architecture we
came up with for Node
ended up being a three
instance node where they're all
talking be a message broker.
We had one instance
that controlled
the API, one instance
the real-time
fetching and stuff.
And the other instance
that kept the [INAUDIBLE]
leaderboard up to date.
It was fine but
again, our application
we're not building
a massive game.
We're just trying to
build something for fun.
I didn't want to
maintain three servers
or have a message broker
dependency and all that stuff.
So with that in mind I
started looking into Dart
and see how can Dart
relieve my pain there.
They both had to win
when my affection.
The investigation
was interesting.
I started looking into it a lot.
I discovered that just doing
Dart on the website and this
was before async 0.8 came out.
This was just when
async 0.8 came out
so doing Dart web
development before and then
coming to async 0.8 on
the server-side and stuff
was really great because
I'm looking at Node.js
and there's a lot of callbacks.
So anyone that's done
Node development,
we end up using promises.
Promises are OK but
you still end up
having this column then
then then then then fail.
So sure it worked but
it wasn't amazing.
And then when I started
looking at Dart's async 0.8
that felt great.
It felt like I
actually felt like all
writing blocking code first.
So I actually had to
get my mind across it
that this was
actually going to work
perfectly fine because the
syntax was that amazing.
And right so before I
get into the differences,
let's talk about a bit
about the similarities
between both platforms.
They're both great platforms
but not putting Node.js down.
Node.js is absolutely amazing.
Lots of large
companies are using it
and Dart is equally
amazing, right.
Lots of large companies as we
saw in the session yesterday,
lots of companies
are using Dart too.
And the benchmarks,
they're both pretty good.
You can't say Dart sucks.
Node.js is faster.
Node.js sucks.
Darts' faster.
They're both equally
sometimes Dart's good.
Sometimes Node.js
is a bit faster.
They're both equal so
I wasn't afraid of that
or I didn't care about
the benchmark stuff.
I just cared about the
language and what it offered.
Both are single threaded
and event based.
And you might notice an asterisk
beside the single threaded
and we'll get to that
in the next slide there.
And both install and run
with a very, very low memory
footprint.
This is not ColdFusion where I
have to get a whole server up
and running and hope to
God everything works fine.
My actual application
ends up being 200 megs.
And they're both JIT compiled
so everything runs fine.
You know all this
stuff looks great.
To me Dart and Node are equally
the same in that aspect.
Differences though
are interesting.
It is a different
programming paradigm.
You know, Dart is
object-oriented,
class based and Node.js
is JavaScript, you know,
all the craziness that
comes a JavaScript.
Node.js, if you want to take
advantage of multiple CPUs,
you have to run multiple
instances of Node
and behind a load balancer.
So when I built a
real-time chat application
that API was clustered
on the 16 core
Amazon CPU and we had a
load balancer in front.
Well all of them talked.
Perfectly fine.
But when you look into Dart
server-side development
you can do the same thing.
At the same time,
you can use isolates.
And isolates lets you run one
node via one Dart instance
and get multiple single threads
running on multiple CPUs.
And we'll get into
isolates in just a second.
This was a personal thing.
There's no forever tool
to restart Dart servers
when they crash.
Node.js [INAUDIBLE]
something crashes you just
restart the whole thing and
hope all the memory problems
are gone.
Dart doesn't have that, but
it's really easy to build.
And I'll show you in a second.
So with that in mind I
said, all right, great.
Dart and Node seem good and
I'm leaning towards Dart
so I might as well
just write a pros
and cons list just to see if I'm
going in the right direction.
Pro for Dart, it's better
profiling and debugging.
I'm using WebStorm and
it is absolutely amazing.
I can step debug than
the entire ID is great.
Everything looks fine to
me and the biggest thing
is Observatory, right.
Node Inspector when
you're actually
profiling Node application
is only so good.
Observatory is like dang.
Another pro is syntax
and language features.
This is a personal
preference and I'm
sure everyone here shares
the same preference.
Dart syntax is great.
Dart's language features are
great compared to JavaScript.
Another one was organization
of code is better and enforced.
So sure you have in Node
you have modules and stuff
but Dart you have classes and
you can extend classes and all
that really, really
fun stuff that
keeps your application sane.
Ane even in your mind keeps
everything very logical.
It supports all major
databases on pub.Dart.
You can find a driver for
most if not all databases
with the exception that
there are some really
esoteric databases that like
came out yesterday that you
won't find Dart support for.
So because they're
building Node.js drivers
but don't trust the database
that came out yesterday.
Now this is a pro and con.
And I really
realized this when I
started talking
to my friend who's
helping me build this
application that there
is a shift in thinking when
you're coming from Node.
You're not thinking
like JavaScript anymore.
You're thinking
class based stuff.
You're thinking about async 0.8.
It kind of takes
a bit of getting
used to if you're
not so familiar
with that type of language.
And we just talked
about esoteric.
So going over all this
stuff I'm like, all right,
you know what, I think
I'm going to go with Dart.
And I clapped and I
danced around a bit.
And I said, OK now what?
Now is the hard part.
I actually have to
port the code over.
So the application, initially,
the Node.js application
was written in Express.
And Express if you don't
know is like the most
popular and powerful
framework in Node.
Almost everyone uses it.
And so I wanted to find the
Express alternative in Dart
because I just want to
make that migration easy.
I didn't want to come up with
a whole new way of writing
API routing and stuff.
So there's actually I found
three promising alternatives
but there are countless
other alternatives.
The three that I found were
Redstone, Shelf and RPC.
Now let's talk a bit about--
let's talk about Redstone.
Has anyone here used
Redstone in the past?
OK, a few of you.
OK, cool.
So Redstone is a API
framework like Express.
It's actively developed
by the community.
It's very, very
express-y and we'll
take a look at a code
snippet in just second.
It's good community support
for middlewares and plugins.
So there's a PostgresSQL Mapper.
There's a MongoDB ORM mapper,
session management stuff,
a static HTML, a server.
So it's pretty,
pretty express-y.
If you take a look at the code,
here's an Express code snippet.
Very easy to understand but
messy because it's JavaScript.
And here is Redstone, right.
Even a preschool kid can go, hey
look, they look really similar.
So Redstone is really, really,
really similar to Express.
And in my opinion it is the
Express of the Dart world.
And so it's really clear.
It's also easy to understand.
And there's good
community support
so if you run into issues,
just ask on Stack Overflow
or just go to the
GitHub issue page
and people will
answer and help out.
But I didn't want to just
go, OK, Redstone, I'm
going to use it.
Forget about the other two.
I wanted to check my options.
I don't want to make a mistake.
So I took a look at Shelf .
Turns out Redstone is actually
built on top of Shelf.
So Shelf is the
base of Redstone.
It's very minimal.
It's not actually
an API framework.
You can use those components to
build an API framework really
easily.
It doesn't have routing.
So if you want to
use routing you
have to use a third
party middleware,
or I think it's
provided by Shelf.
And a bunch of
Redstone's middlewares
are actually Shelf's middlewares
so if you are using Redstone
you can get all of Shelf's
middlewares running there.
And it's a simple API so let's
take a look at an Express
example.
That's how Express is.
And if you take a look at Shelf
that's how Shelf is, right.
Again, very simple.
So if you don't really
need all of Redstone's
powerful features, you just want
to build a very bare bones API,
then go with Shelf.
It's easy.
And it's also made
by the Dart team
so you're not going
to go wrong there.
The last one that
I found was RPC.
And this was an interesting one.
RPC is a package for building
RESTful server-side RPC style
APIs.
And it's the newest
one of the two.
It actually just went public
a few months ago I think.
And it's interesting
because you can write--
when you write an API
it's very self-documenting
and that's what I loved a lot.
You're using a lot of
annotations kind of like Shelf
but you're adding a bit more
information to your API.
So if we take a look at Express.
Again, we're all going
to use that example.
Here's the RPC example.
You know, you're
importing a toyapi.dart.
And we'll take a look at what
toyapi is in the next slide.
And then you've
got an API server.
You're adding it and you're
setting up a Discovery API
and then you're saying, hey,
I'm listening on port 8080.
toyapi.dart is just a class that
you can have your gets, puts,
posts, all that stuff there.
And It's very easy and you can
see that it's very descriptive
An Android developer
like the developer
that built the app
can come on and be
like OK, that's the actual API.
I don't have to generate lots
and lots of documentation
for it.
So it's a bit more verbose.
It's not as clean.
I mean it is clean but it's not
as short as Redstone or Shelf.
But I think I like it because
it's very self-documenting.
One great feature
about it though,
that you can generate
client-side libraries
using Google's Discovery
Document Format.
So you can have client-side
libraries for Java, Python,
a bunch of crazy stuff.
And it's great.
And again, it's made
by that Dart team
so you can't go wrong there.
I went with RPC.
Next, the requirement
here was we
had this Socket.IO server
pushing stock quotes
to the Android devices.
So we had to find a Socket.IO
alternative for Dart.
Luckily, we didn't
have to go far.
Dart comes natively
with WebSockets.
This was an amazing feature.
All I had to do literally was
new WebSocket and it worked.
This is WebSocket's
integrated with Dart RPC.
So I'm listening
to RPC, then I'm
saying OK, if the web
request path is [? WS ?],
then pass that to the
web transformer upgrade.
And then handle all the messages
that come into the socket.
Done.
We had WebSockets working.
We had the API working.
Great, so how do we
get them all together?
Actually write all this stuff.
Yes.
OK.
So thinking in Dart.
This was the most
key thing that I
discovered while writing
Market Wolf in Dart.
Our basic API,
just to reiterate,
was our basic
architecture was we had
to fetch stocks in real-time.
We had to keep the leaderboard
updated in real-time.
And we also had to serve
all the API requests.
Node single event
loop [INAUDIBLE]
back because there's lots
of processing happening
at every event loop so we ended
up splitting it into three.
Here's the architecture
again if you guys forgot.
Three stuff there.
But in Dart it's very
easy to replicate that.
I can literally just run
three Dart instances,
put a load
[INAUDIBLE] the front.
Everything works.
But I found out about
isolates and that just
changed my entire
way of thinking.
Isolates are pretty interesting.
Every Dart application
runs in an isolate so
when you first
run an application
that itself an isolate.
An isolate is an
independent worker
that runs on its own
memory so you can't
have variables being shared.
But if you do want to
talk to other isolates
you can talk to them via
send and receive ports.
What's great about this is
we took those three cores
and I made that
into three isolates.
I had one isolate serving
all the API stuff,
one isolate for
the stock venture,
and one isolate for
the real-time stuff.
All of them are running on one
VM instance but on three cores.
It actually made
ops a lot easier.
I just had one server.
I didn't have to deal with load
balances or anything like that.
Here's how you just
talk to an isolate.
You create a new receiver
port, you spot an isolate,
serviceisolate.leaderboard
service
is actually the
method that's going
to run inside the isolate.
That has a for loop I think,
or a while loop, just fetching
stocks constantly.
And then I start the isolate up.
This fit perfectly
with our design.
So if we take a look at our
node architecture, and now
our Dart architecture, it's all
very self-contained, very nice.
It works perfectly
fine and each isolate
takes a very, very low amount
of memory, just 1.5 megs.
And it's light weight
enough to do the job well.
I've heard that the Dart
team is improving the API,
going to make that even smaller
so that's no cost to running
isolates.
What's cool is
that you can listen
to isolates get created and
die so if we go back to that
forever in Node where
whenever a Node app dies
you can just restart it.
You can actually just
listen to your API
isolate or any of these
other isolates and go hey,
did you die?
Why did you die?
OK, I'm going to restart.
So you can have this
constant as soon
as it crashes restart the app
again, send out a crash report,
whatever.
You can do all that stuff.
You can also steal across
multiple servers, right?
There's nothing stopping
you from taking this
and creating four other
servers and putting
inside a load balancer.
Isolates just logically
they make clear sense to me
and when you're writing
code it actually
works really, really well.
Isolates are a game changer
when you develop and imagine
if you're doing long running
database operations you
can just launch an isolate.
It does its stuff
in the back-end
and just goes to sleep.
So now we had all this working.
I was happy but then we ran
into bugs unfortunately.
So or fortunately
actually because in Node,
console.log becomes
your best friend.
All you do in Node.js
is console.log.
And then as a last
resort you'll set up
like breakpoint debugging
or go to Node Inspector
and try to figure
all that stuff out.
So especially when
you have a memory leak
you're kind of out
of luck on Node.
You got to start
up Node Inspector,
really try to find out
what's happening there.
But we had a memory leak
with our stock fetcher.
Something was leaking.
Luckily, Dart comes
with Observatories.
Everyone knows.
And that made the process
of debugging so much easier.
And what's great
is you can listen,
you can look at all your
isolates in this memory map.
So I didn't have to go
look through tons and tons
of stack traces
to find out where
my isolate was being executed.
All I had to do was
just click on OK,
here's my stock fetcher isolate.
Let's see what's
happening in there.
I can also see all the memory
stuff with the foreign isolate,
see how much memory
it's taking, see
what's taking a lot of
memory, how much is free,
how much is not free, see
the heat map, the allocation
profile.
So we ended up having
where the hashmap that
held onto the stocks
kept increasing.
We weren't clearing stuff out.
It was getting way too large.
So using Observatory we solved
that in like ten minutes.
And then we can get
back to dancing around.
So debugging in Dart
was absolutely amazing.
Everything was ready to go.
We were about to launch
this and we were like OK,
we forgot a step.
We actually have to
deploy it to the server.
So how are we going to
deploy it to the server?
Originally, the application
used AWS Beanstalk.
So the first thing I did
was log onto aws.com,
go to new instance
for Beanstalk,
and then get bummed out
that this says no JS, PHP,
Python, but no Dart.
Right?
However, implicitly
it did say Dart.
It said Docker.
And what's great
is that you can run
Dart on any server that supports
Docker because the Google
team-- skip a bit here.
The Google team has already
deployed, already built
a Docker image for us
to deploy on Beanstalk.
If you don't know what Beanstalk
is Beanstalk is really just
an easy way to run your
application on Amazon's cloud
and they'll handle auto
provisioning, scaling,
load balancing for you.
So you don't have
to set all that up.
You just have to create servers
and tell Amazon these are
the servers I want you to use.
Go nuts.
And so Amazon will
do that for you.
So Docker file is
really simple to use.
It's like
1-2-3-4-5-6-7-8-9-10 lines.
And you've got your
application ready to go.
I import from Google/Dart.
I create my working directory.
I add the pubspec.
I add all the files.
I do pub get.
And then I expose
the port on 3030.
And then I tell Docker when
you run, call bin/server.dart.
Now that we had that ready
there's just one more thing
that you need to do on AWS.
You need to create a
[? dockerfile.aws.json. ?]
And what that tells AWS
is, hey, my Docker instance
is going to run on port
3030 so keep that in mind
when I'm deploying.
So expose the port, set up the
right firewall configurations,
load balancing, all the
crazy stuff that you do.
Once you have that
really it's just
a matter of using their
AWS command line tools
and typing in eb deploy.
It's the most simplest way
to deploy a Dart application
in my opinion.
eb deploy, it
uploads it, runs it.
Everything's great.
Alternatively, what
you could also do
was use a service like
a continuous integration
service like Codeship.
So I ended up doing, ended up
writing a bunch of unit tests
and whenever I do git push
origin master whatever,
Codeship would pick that up,
figure it out, run its unit
tests on it.
Once that's done it
without automatically
deploy to AWS Beanstalk
with the right Docker
file and Docker AWS.
So there was this continuous
loop of continuous integration
and deployment.
That's actually what I
did like ten minutes ago
when I had to make sure
the stock stuff was
all dynamic and random.
Was all this worth it?
Apparently not.
All right.
So was all this worth it?
I think it took us
about a week to do this.
Not a lot of manpower
but really took
already something that worked
and just moved it to Dart.
I think it was.
There's no question about it.
Dart's syntax, the
language features,
isolates, Observatory, all
that really, really cool stuff,
made a compelling
case to move to Dart.
Like when I look
back on Node.js code
it feels like I'm
writing assembly.
Right, it's just
very archaic now.
There's lots of callbacks,
stuffs all over the place,
and just feels weird.
Do we find anything missing that
we go OK, I wish Dart had that.
Node.js does.
Absolutely not.
Everything that
we needed in terms
of the packages, the tooling,
the support, the language
features, everything's
there in Dart.
Actually there's stuff
missing from Node.
And the number lines of code
shrunk dramatically too.
I think that's because of
all the callbacks and stuff.
But also because stuff's easier.
We don't have to import a lot
of dependencies and set that up.
Socket.IO is a dependency.
So you have to set that up.
In Dart it's just new WebSocket.
And there's a bunch
of other examples
where it was just really,
really simple to get Dart up
and running.
Whereas Node you had to
import a few libraries
just to make that
code more sane.
In short, moving
from Node.js to Dart
was the best decision we made.
For us all API
projects moving forward
will be written in Dart.
So any new, cool thing I
do that will be in Dart.
Thank you.